у
Добрий день дорогі друзі шановні
освітяни
дорогі учні шановні пане посол Мені дуже
приємно що велика спільна робота України
Китайської Народної Республіки
гуманітарної освітньої допомоги майже
практичне втілення і зокрема одна з
багатьох багатьох шкіл по всій Україні
це 194 школа
Оболонського району міста Київ Я хотів
би сказати кілька слів про цей
унікальний проект від народився півтора
роки тому під час державного візиту
президента України Віктора Федоровича
Януковича і його особистої зустрічі
переговорів з головою Китайської
Народної Республіки
під час державного візиту коли президент
України і високоповажні банку дзвінка
обговорювали ще більш тісної економічної
співпраці у
сторонніх проблем які мають іти на
користь українського народу і народу
Китайської Народної Республіки зокрема
було прийнято рішення що уряд Китайської
Народної Республіки надає допомогу
заради покращення якості освіти і
літаками наприкінці серпня після того
була велика робота
підписана була угода між нашим Кабінету
Міністрів і урядом Китайської Народної
Республіки і 15 тисяч новеньких
комп'ютерів з
Китайської Народної Республіки
безкоштовно як гуманітарний вантаж
проекту обох президентів
дружніх держав прийшли за два дні
працівники центрального апарату
Міністерства як заправский вантажники
розвантажили це прямо на полі Борисполя
і дощ з
героїчними зусиллями але Повірте що
32000 коробок і це це облікувати
розробити забрали гості ми передали всім
регіонам самі вирішують керівники разом
з педагогічною громадою
обласних управлінь освіти і формують вже
навчально-виховні комплекси залежно від
потреби школи під час робочих місць +
місце вчителя до більш великих класи 15
12 + 1 це блискучий початок Я дуже радий
що в цьому проекті перед участь
уряд Китайської Народної Республіки тому
що Україну і Китай і дають
відносини справжньої дружби багатолітній
справжнього партнерства і не тільки на
політичному вимірі на вимірі держав
людських стосунків хочу сказати що одні
з кращих студентів іноземців які у
багатьох університетах нашої країни це
молоді хлопці і дівчата з Китайської
Народної Республіки А зараз дорогі друзі
шановні вчителі Я хочу з великою
приємністю запросити до вітального слова
надзвичайного і повноважного посла
Китайської Народної Республіки будь
ласка
Прекрасна
міністра [ __ ] касарес сукня
чтоб
всего
участников и
а
директор з
під
час росту
і о
у
наших
Спасибо
огромное Спасибо
вам
хочем сказати вчителі про це добре
знають першого вересня цього року наша
початкова школа починає працювати за
новим державним стандартом і переваги
його революційність тому що ми починаємо
в усіх школах України це 19800 шкільних
вивчення іноземної мови з першого класу
і нового предмету інформатика сходинки
до інформатики з другого класу друга
іноземна мова приходить усі школи
п'ятого класу
Я дуже багато й новації більше всього ми
приділяємо увагу технічних і природничих
предметом фізика математика хімія
астрономія Я думаю буде правильно
господаря запросити дозволу директора
194 школи Віталій Михайлович площа він
вже буде реалізовувати разом своїми
однодумцями з колективом нової стандарти
дуже добре що новий комп'ютерний клас
тому що сходинки до інформатики ще
почнуть вивчати діти другого класу
господарем
за такий чудовий проект Дякую Дмитра
Володимировича і
Дякуємо за таку чудову нагоду для наших
дітей вчителів
познайомитися з новітньою технікою
також освоїти нові програми зокрема одну
із систем
а
й має розповсюдженням світі
ми зможемо побачити як воно працює
досить вдалі дає результати Наші учні
сьогодні навіть зробили презентації
на китайською мовою російською
українською сьогодні все це ви можете
побачити
щоб не затримувати всіх нас Тому як і
запрошую до школи
фотографії з
о.в.